good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this evening's meeting of the
Southeastern area planning committee
um most of you know Derek Lawrence I
think but for those of you who don't
he's been here before has he decided
we're needed controlling so he's come
back again
thank you
[Laughter]
that sounds familiar name
um gender item one Chairman's notices
there were two notices recording of the
meeting please note that the council
will be recording and Publishing on the
council's website any part of this
meeting held in Open Session
and the second part is fire in the event
of a fire officers will notify those
present if you haven't already found out
for yourselves please use a fire exit at
the back of the room and out the door
marked with the green Running Man the
five assembly point is Barclays Bank car
park please gather there and await
further instruction
agenda item 2 apologies for absence I
know councilor Beale
okay thank you
for gender item three minutes of the
last meeting
87 to 14 has anybody got any questions
or
clarifications they're all happy
thank you
agenda item for disclosure of Interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests and
non-registerable interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph 9
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they also
require to disclose any such interest as
soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting and I
will declare a interest in the
knowing the applicant of a gender item
six
everybody's going to say the same right
okay that's simple thank you
uh gender items
yes please
item six Gemini I've got a disclosable
pecunity
I'll leave the I'll leave the
the five and I think we've ordered a
range where you'll meet me he's not
coming back
um agenda items five and six I believe
will the office of presenting it will be
Lisa Greenwood who's doing it remotely
with support from Derek as we need it
and also apparently we've got their Sean
Jones who's going to be a new committee
clerk for us at some stage
right agenda item five the ridings
Burnham Road Lexington Essex it's a
retention of a dwelling is as built so
it's a
it's one after the event detached garage
and Associated works and the reason it's
here is the departure from the local
plan 2017 with a recommendation to
approve
Lisa
not present
when are you ready
outside
the site comprises of a single story
dwelling detached garage and a large
area of standing at the frontage all of
which
foreign
this remote idea is not a very good one
is it
um
[Music]
Lisa I think you better go back to
beginning and start again hello can you
hear us
go back to beginning and start again
the site prizes the sequel story do I
need to tax marriage and large area of
hard standing at the frontage all of
which are the subjects of disappear
here
[Music]
the development has already
conditions related to the approved
application
and they were not discharged and the
position permission is no longer
considered to be expand the tradition
seeking approval relates to drainage
parking and balancing treatments
it should be noted for the external
design and footprint of the Bungalow is
identical to that of the approved
dwelling it's 16.5 meters wide and has a
maximum depth of 11 meters it measures
5.5 meters in height and is finishing in
Brick and tile
the access is located to the
northeastern corner of the site the
changes are set out to paragraph 3.1.6
of the officer's reports are summarized
as follows
the cartilage has increased in width
from 29 meters to 36 meters in width
details for the drainage of the sites
are located to the east of the dwelling
outside of the residential personage
the original application was both
three-bedroom Bungalow and this is a
two-bedroom balcony
the Bongos being constructed using a
slightly different boundary line
slightly further east and further from
the neighboring red rides Lodge the
current application includes a garage
hard standing to the front and around
the dwelling and Associated works
although the 2016 commission is no
longer exact it is not considered that
there are changes to the dwelling to the
site or policy that are significant
enough to alter the Stars taken to the
previous application it should be noted
that the 2016 application is recommended
for approval by officers and the
planning committee this application
follows a previous application at the
site of January 2030 which was
recommended for refusal by officers but
granting permission to buy the committee
it's not considered that the alterations
have resulted in development which will
harm to the character and appearance at
the countryside which would have
Justified a reason for refusal
a significant area of hard standing
however has been built at the site
surrounding the dwelling and extended
significantly onto the site particularly
the frontage and the Eastern section
however it is considered that subjects
to an appropriate condition reducing the
hard sounding and ensuring that it's
appropriate Landscaping is achieved the
development would not result in any
significant harm to the Landscaping
character of the area there has been
made of technical or Naval rejection to
proceed and it is therefore recommended
that subject to the imposition
conditions the planning permission is
wanted
thank you very much
we have no public speakers on this one
so Ward members no problem with the
recommendation chairman
Council Fluker I wonder if the officer
can just confirm whether or not this
excuse me hard standing at the front is
permeable if that's the right word and
also I'm going back if we could just
have the site plan up I think you've got
an attenuation Pond or Ah that's the one
so
[Music]
I can't it says drainage something
rather say some base so that actual
Basin
um Falls within the cartilage of this
application
uh so that's so there's two questions
but not
so it's within the land owned by the
African but we 've got with so many
Class Acts Residential Care stage but
you can tie the drainage to the bank so
we can have a condition on there if we
think and and do we know if the the
drainage basin is sufficient for just
one building
yes I don't think there are any issues
so it looks amazing so you've got a
looks like where your cursor was you've
got sort of a cloud gesture system and
then that's going into a drainage basin
would that be correct
weather rounds so yeah yeah so you've
got you've got a tree going into a
drainage base and my understanding that
clarkes has had to go into a ditch of
running water or if not into uh the head
of the ditch but that might be something
that's building regulations and need to
be confirmed but my understanding is and
I've been involved in a lot of car
gesture installations
um and then the one on the permeability
of the
surface of the car parking
I wonder if we can have an answer on
that with Greenwood
be hard standing
but you're not the hard standing is
permeable I don't believe that all the
sessions are permeable however we are
meant to have the hard starting reduced
so no I think in our mind this
this is the finished article and we are
proposing the condition
um whereby the applicants
for the correct amount and type of hard
standing that we would deem acceptable
because at the moment we just feel it's
far too extensive and it if it wasn't
approved as part of the original
application so we have to sort to be
honest further details on this because
this is something that's going to be
subject to change well chairman I'm
sorry disappointed Clarity if the
officer doesn't support the amount of
hard standing looks
on the application then surely that's
the reason for the officers to recommend
the refusal because I don't see how you
can condition it by saying it's got to
be reduced I mean I don't I think Mr
Lawrence we can impose Contrition
because as the officer has explained at
the moment as it stands there is no
planning permission right it's a
retrospective so we are considering it
in its entirety
I mean it's
slightly new one to me because you've
you've got something that's already
there which is
globally you're saying you you the
officers
that the officers want to reduce the
amount of hard standing and one hopes
that through that I don't know but then
that would they would mean that they
would have to be perfect it can be
controlled by a condition obviously what
it will do as I understand it the
existing hard standing is is a is a
non-permeable Surface it's this I think
it's gravels it's uh sit in the kind of
bitumen so obviously it does have a
fairly impermeability but what we are
seeking to achieve is by reducing the
amount of the area that will assist in
in any runoff of surface water on the
site my only concern is
attention
to Road outside
but so can we can the officer please
show us the the extent of the hard
standing now and what the officers are
going to propose to the applicant
this is the extent of the hard standing
now that you can see on photographs
taken by
Vicky who was the case Doctor
and then if I'm just flick up then you
can see here the map
there
so I'm sorry gentle through you so we
don't that that Clan there is proposed
or proposed by the officer or is that as
it is now no no
so what they've had to do because they
haven't built the house well they have
the um stances
accept your plans they've had to come in
with a retrospect application for the
entire site for us to assess
um we don't feel that the background
there are no real changes
um we don't feel that it it deems a need
to be refusal as we're comfortable with
the fact that you're spoken without
publicity enforcement that we can do
this that we can achieve
foreign
we have imposed a timeline in terms of
the condition
um if you look in the report it does
refer to a timeline which they would
have to submit those details they'd have
to submit them for our consideration and
approval and then if they weren't
submitted in that time then effectively
there would not be a planning permission
and after that period we would then look
to seek to take enforcement actually so
I can I can see the conditions is quite
robust but I think it would have been
helpful to have a plan what the
council's proposing but if it if the
offices are
intended that we can control the
response conditions yes
recommendation to I can't confirm it's a
robust condition
oh don't say that it would be terrible
trouble
yes right okay
council Mrs stem yeah can it not be
strengthened the last sentence on
condition one then because cancer Luke
has made excellent points about it is
permeable I've read it and I can't say
the word is permeable
can that not just be strengthened in
there so it is going to be permeable of
its current standards on you we do have
the ability to amend the conditions such
that it will be a permanent the
alternative that they do adopt is where
you have the non-permeable service
normally there is like a gully Works
adjacent to the highway and it goes in
that it that it takes the rainfall off
into that that would be shall I say a
more appropriate solution that they
could install just one of these cast
iron gullies across the actual vehicular
access as long as they keep it clean yes
because it wants that gets off all it
does is is run off I don't mind if it's
not but you know it just strengthens
what cancer blue could say I've got a
question just in general burners now
we've got Mr Lawrence here and um about
cartilage I can remember sitting in this
chamber when men gaps Manor wanted to
build a garage to put his cars and it
was outside the cartilage and we had
murders here didn't we it got refused
and then we had everything else and it
just seems to me that this application
is not built within the cartilage and it
and it seems to be okay and what's what
concerns me and I'm preempting if I get
an email tomorrow morning in my inbox
saying why was it queried and that
that's been allowed to stand when the
other didn't it's actually I think I
can't remember we virtually if it was
improved but there was a lot of
difficulty about it being outside the
cartilage so can I have some
explanations yes when we talk about
residential sorry when we talk
residential cartilage it's normally that
area immediately around the property
um we do have the cases where some
people say it's within the cartilage but
it's the area which is immediately
adjacent to the building but what they
have done is included the drainage
within the overall application site so
it is controllable but but that's what
courses means it's it's what you would
normally assume with the garden yeah and
it's what is reasonable there's no
precise definition of what is a
cartilage it it really it's a matter of
shall I say fact and degree of what
constitutes occursions but it's normally
that area which is immediately adjacent
to the property
the planning department wishes to be as
small as possible the applicant wishes
it to be as big as possible so you end
up with a compromise I'm in the middle
of all of that thank you Jim
installation guidelines for cloud
Jesters I see environmental health don't
have any objection
um
but the environment agency on involved
in this so I did wonder whether or not
we can have a condition that satisfies
the installation about going into
what's not running water in a pot
because I know every single car just a
sales rep will say to you you can drink
the water as it comes out of the car
gesture
but when they go wrong it's catastrophic
and having it all going into a pond
basically surrounded by houses so I do
wonder if it's possible to have some
kind of condition on there because the
environment agency haven't responded to
this but environmental health care I
think that's an existing situation with
the largest I think what the new part is
that they've provided the drainage as
you've seen in the diagram
which is
that's the area adjacent to the site I
think the collages so that was an
existing installation installed with the
property but I don't remember it
I don't remember it discharging into a
new pod
I mean obviously that's something we've
in terms of the technical details we've
consulted the Environmental Health
Department there are they are our
advisors if there was any
pollution implications bearing in mind
the size of this like it's not something
which we would normally consult the
environment agency but the environmental
health officer is satisfied that what
they have been stored is acceptable
but I only chairman only queried it
because I know in the past applications
have been turned down where it's
impossible to connect to humans the main
sewage system and you can't install
anything else other than a septic tank
because there's nowhere for a cladjuster
to discharge into so you know if
environmental health are happy they're
happy but I'm just a tad concerned
cancer boys
um I'm rather surprised about Carl just
has been used on this site because
they're online Series right outside the
front door
well um
are we not are we all not a little bit
confused here and that that drainage
space and it's just dealing with surface
water but it does the way the drawing is
drawn it I can't believe what it says
next to the circle but normally it
that's how the largest of which Bridge
would be shown
it just says
is it a smaller I might have to do is
actually open the plans to do so because
it's not coming very very clearly
5.7 says it's not connected
it's disconnected
no it does say it's connected to the
main phase
board the drainage report has been
submitted and surface water is dealt
with by a soak away yes okay
[Music]
because as it's a two-bedroom property
in terms of the car parking requirements
only a single garage is required but
equally there is space on the hard
standing for any visitors cars yeah it
seems a big structure for us
yeah it looked for me well yeah
whatever
right recommendation to prove everybody
happy with that show yes like that's
great thank you
thank you
look what
uh Tyler please note um has left the
room
um agenda item six the wheat bun
keelings Road
dingy says South Municipal is denji
southminster
um
construction of garden produce and
garden equipment store and existing
concrete base reason for referral to
this committee is that the applicant is
a counselor with a recommendation to
approve subject to the conditions as
detailed in Section 8 of this report
Lisa please present
ation
[Music]
to the wheat bar a great University
building one Annex one cartwatch and
workshop one oil tank and one Pond the
wheat bun is an early example of a brick
Barn irritable District following its
designation in 1986 the barn was in
32-20
besides his name to a number of Heritage
assets to the northern UC Davis
Countryside and the character of the
science is rural
planning permission is sought with an
instruction of garden produce and garden
equipment store to be sighted on top of
an existing concrete base
paragraph 3.1.4 of the office's report
sets out the specifications to the store
which is proposed to measure five meters
in depth 9.1 meters in width and 4
meters in height to the Vigilant hitch
roof which is 2.7 meters to the eaves
the soul will be constructed with a
corrugated sheep roof Timber
weatherboarding painted black and will
have a half glaze climber door and six
meters so the front elevation will
remain open to allow access
as stated the wheat bath is a rated
listed building and there are a number
of Heritage assets within close boxes as
you decide as such the proposal has been
reviewed by the council's conservation
officer who has noted that the proposed
outfielder would pose no conflicts with
positive detailing of the local
development plan Northern National
planning policy framework or section 66
one of the planning listed buildings and
conservation areas act 1990
the building will be partially screened
by existing Hedges and as the site
benefits from a generous plot the
outbuilding would not have been a large
in relation to the existing Barn it
would also not detract from any
important views or from the list of
building itself there have been no labor
or technical objections received and it
is therefore recommended that subjects
were conditioned regarding materials
Planning Commission is granted
okay thank you very much
as board member I have no further
comment to make on it any other members
is that agreed
thank you very much
gender item sixth agreed agenda item
seven any other items of business
that the chairman of the committee
decides are Urgent I have none so I will
close the meeting at 7 70 6. thank you
members